hey guys
mkbhd here back with another
high-definition video and a quick one
regarding the 10,000 subscribers to the
mkbhd youtube channel today i have a
quick giveaway video for you guys just
because I feel the need to give back to
you guys
you might remember I reviewed the beats
by dre solo HD is not too long ago those
were provided by monster cable today I'm
going to be giving away a second pair of
beats by dre so HD is that I actually
purchased myself hopefully these are on
the frame here I have to do to win a
pair of these headphones these are
really nice headphones is just leave a
comment I want my beats second thing you
have to do is like this video and as
long as you're a subscriber you are
eligible to win and I'll be picking the
winner in exactly a week so the more
comments you leave the more entries you
technically have but don't go overboard
because you don't want your comment to
be marked as spam until next time this
has been mkbhd again super fast video
hopefully you and these new headphones
thanks for watching
peace